y ella
me complace anunciar hoy que tras meses
de duras y meditadas negociaciones creo
que tenemos un histórico sé que tenemos
un marco económico histórico
con este anuncio el presidente
estadounidense se despidió antes de
viajar rumbo hacia una serie de cumbres
en europa el histórico marco al que se
refiere se alcanzó tras una reunión con
los demócratas en el congreso para la
aprobación de un paquete económico de
índole social y ambiental pero el
ambicioso proyecto inicial de unos 3.5
billones fue reducido a la mitad para
ganarse la voluntad de los últimos
demócratas escépticos wissmann ahora
pasamos horas y horas y horas durante
meses y meses trabajando en esto nadie
consiguió todo lo que quería incluido yo
pero eso es lo que es el compromiso las
cosas así 1.75 billones de dólares serán
inyectados los próximos diez años en la
economía estadounidense el plan
consistirá en 550 millones de dólares
que se invertirán en la transición
ecológica y abordará también el problema
de la pobreza
de la desigualdad con subsidios
familiares mensuales y construcciones de
viviendas pero retrocediendo en materia
de beneficios parentales y deteniendo la
revisión de precios de medicamentos
por ello el ala más progresista del
partido de bailén se mostró insatisfecha
nuestros corazones se rompen todas las
mujeres aquí todas las familias la
licencia con goce de sueldo no está no
está en el marco que estableció el
presidente y no se está rompiendo el
corazón y esperamos que tal vez algo
cambie pero al menos con el marco que
existe podemos respaldarlo en principio
pero necesitamos tener el texto
legislativo y votaremos ambos proyectos
de ley juntos en medio del desencuentro
los debates al proyecto de modernización
de infraestructuras por un billón de
dólares continúan